the city of san francisco has just
declared a state of emergency
in response to coronavirus and yet
you'll remember that for a month
western leaders told us that the virus
was under control and was unlikely to
cause serious problems for
anyone in our hemisphere none of that
was true
but saying it was less painful than
rethinking the failed theology of
globalism so they went with it
meanwhile in china an aggressively
nationalist country that if nothing else
definitely doesn't hate itself
authorities acted immediately and with
force
with military grade discipline they shut
down the city of wuhan home to 11
million people
the rest of the world watched this
happen in real time
but yet assured themselves that
everything was fine
it wasn't fine we know that now at least
35 countries have confirmed cases of
chronovirus as of tonight last friday
italy reported six
yet at midday today they had 283 and
then by tonight
that number had risen to 322 that is a
steep
trajectory so far 11 people have died in
italy and parts of the country are
shutting down
iran has confirmed 15 deaths plus 95
cases of the real numbers believed to be
higher than that
one of those infected is the country's
own deputy health minister
who was seen sweating profusely on
monday at a press conference
downplaying the outbreak he later
appeared on an iranian news program to
reassure the country that everything was
under control
and then he coughed on the woman
interviewing him
in this country there are more than 50
confirmed cases today the centers for
disease control confirmed that a
generalized
outbreak is inevitable here quote
it's not a question of if this will
happen but when
officials warned americans to be ready
for severe disruptions to their lives
include dividing students into smaller
groups or
in a severe pandemic closing schools and
using internet-based
telescoping to continue education for
adults
businesses can replace in-person
meetings with video or telephone
conferences
and increase teleworking options on a
larger scale
communities and cities may need to
modify postpone or cancel mass
gatherings
disruption to everyday life may be
severe but these
are things that people need to start
thinking about now people are concerned
about the situation
i would say rightfully so i'm concerned
about the situation
cdc is concerned about the situation
so what exactly will a coronavirus
pandemic mean for this country
well of course you can't really say it's
impossible to predict with
with precision but here's one forecast
that caught our eyes from the atlantic
is titled you're likely to get the
coronavirus the piece quotes extensively
a harvard epidemiologist
the article describes him as a cautious
professional the kind of person who
carefully considers every word and then
backs it with data what the professor
told the magazine
is this quote i think the likely outcome
is that coronavirus will ultimately not
be containable
he went on to predict that in the next
year 40 to seventy percent of the people
on
earth will be infected with coronavirus
now not all of them will become ill
many he says will be asymptomatic or
feel no worse than they do with a cold
but nevertheless seventy percent of the
world's population is a big number in
fact it's
4.5.4 billion people
currently the chronovirus appears to
kill about 2 percent of the people who
have it
so let's be generous for a moment and
imagine that asymptomatic carriers are
not detected and the real death rate is
only say
half a percent that would be one quarter
of the current estimates
even under that scenario there would
still be 27 million deaths from
coronavirus globally
in this country more than a million
would die
and according to the atlantic many
experts fear this may not be a one-off
epidemic cold and flu season could
become cold flu and coronavirus season
for this foreseeable future will that
happen well obviously we're praying that
it doesn't
but we know one thing right now as of
tonight america is not ready for this or
for any major epidemic
thanks to the cdc's flawed rollout of
chronovirus testing
few locations in this country are even
prepared to monitor
coronavirus and the economy of course
isn't prepared either the dow jones just
fell close to 900 points today
that's on top of yesterday's thousand
point drop overall u.s markets are down
eight to nine percent compared to
earlier this month
if that continues it's not good